street vape have you ever had a stream
fail ken because i have not thanks for
asking no
i didn't even think about that
damn it yeah me neither clearly all
right
deflect what are you what about you ken
come on don't do me like that no of
course not i've never street failed cool
we're squeaky clean let's go
oh so if i start cinnamon toast stream
fail what is going to show up oh
nothing just my own videos well i got
banned on twitch one time because i
streamed a nfl football game
[Laughter]
of course well let's look at other
people fail this streamer's girlfriend
fell off the ramp and into the water
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh she's swedish too the chinese swedish
or maybe norwegian even better oh that's
so good
where is she oh my gosh bro this has
happened to me like 600 times i don't
know why as a kid 600 600 times i was
gonna jump from the front of the boat
and my dad started reversing as soon as
i jumped splash
everyone thought it was so funny
they had such a troll and to the rails i
had my phone in my pocket and they had
to buy a new one
okay how old are you when that happened
like 14 14 you had a phone
dude yeah
i didn't get my own cell phone until i
was a man like i moved to the house and
i got my own cell phone dude we had the
those brick phones me and my sister got
to share it but you know the first
version of a phone that was literally
this big
yeah yeah we had those
who had the snake high score
that one that didn't even have snake
dude
that was so old
holy crap it's just because we have to
walk home from school and my mom was
like here call me if there's a problem
the thing i appreciate about this clip
right here though she doesn't drag the
dog in with her she lets go with the dog
yeah yeah
i respect her for that this live
streamer was playing a scary game and
got a very bad jump scare when an enemy
came right in front of her
mr x is coming
oh that's just cringe dude who would
possibly react like that
from a horror again
oh i like how she like
she checks herself in obs to while she's
doing it see what she looks like
[Laughter]
oh gotta see just
yeah
[Laughter]
yeah i remember back in the day playing
amnesia you know sometimes you play the
game right and then you use bandicam or
something or fraps you corrupt all your
data yeah sure you'd have to reshoot it
those scares are so much better the
second time man when you really just put
it on you know what you say are you
saying you you faked your scares
listen okay there's a game called five
nights at freddy's
yeah that one was never scary that one's
never after the first three times you're
just like okay ah that was torture right
them youtubers man you gotta throw your
head back
cover your face
so scary every single time it it is
better clearly if you look at the
viewfinder then you almost get that
scary face
this streamer realized watching all
these stream files is like going back in
time on youtube like all this [ __ ] that
you had to do back in the day to get
people to watch you
i just got my headphones on without the
cat ears oh boy
nice
i strongly feel that way that like
twitch is
four years behind youtube at all times
yeah it does seem like i'm looking at
this
eating spicy stuff ain't doing that for
views that's pathetic the spicy hot chip
that was like freaking four years ago
bro
they'll be doing cinnamon challenge or
whatever it's called challenge is coming
very soon it's coming up
a chubby bunny challenge any milk in his
house
she drank all the milk you don't want
any i thought it was for [ __ ]
i'm fine i seen this one it's not even
good wrong during live stream
wait we saw this right
where people link stuff for me to watch
what website is that
like how she looks so surprised like she
just didn't have that
what do you mean
what do you mean
[Applause]
[Music]
i would scream too that's literally
money going out the drain you're about
to get banned people leak stuff to her
is that what it is yeah i didn't
understand okay i thought she like
opened up her own like bookmark or
something and i get it
oh my bookmark
i can't believe i just showed you guys
the chair couldn't hold his weight and
he fell on his back during the live
stream
watch
i'm not going to fall but
oh my god
that's a good feeling actually
oh
of people came for him by messaging on
his playstation while he was live
streaming a game wait a minute
this is funniest live stream fans what's
funny about things
trust me there's nothing this is another
message oh i don't care
oh my god please
why i hate you all so much you ruin all
fun i hope you get banged this life
it took a long time to get that game
started all right i was excited i
literally just got into it and then all
these kids going
it's like why do you do this what is
wrong with you it makes it so funny to
me because i know that you're actually
mad but yeah
there's something about you like the way
you speak and you're like charisma that
even when you're mad it still seems
funny but uh
oh man
they cut the best part when i said that
what no live streamer has ever dared to
say we're not friends
what
my social relationship
oh my god
but i gave you money
but bro i don't know
while playing the game
bro
you know that would scare me tim oh my
[ __ ] god
did it even jump
where is steve and basically he's right
there like
he's up there by the washing machine
my voice hurts
oh god a streamer's cat accidentally
pushed the hot key on the keyboard that
started a stream while the trailer was
still asleep that's good it's 6 am and
his friend called him up to make him
aware of the situation
[Music]
come on why do the friends have to call
that's what i want to know oh yeah
without the headphones does it hear his
computer going off i guess
what's his phone
guy sleeps with a bandana what the [ __ ]
is this
yeah he's so gangster bro who sleeps
with the bandana that's so weird how
many of these are legit like i don't
you know you're you're okay how do we
talk about this you go into your your
area your recording streaming area you
know you sit down your computer
you know you're like hmm
i want to open up i wanna i wanna open
up what pokeman opened up you know uh
uh-huh
let me make sure my streaming stuff is
turned off or maybe even that my
camera's not on i don't know
maybe he has a webcam or something this
guy just leaves it on all the time got
the screen on like blaring like i think
i think he just wanted to flex that he
sleeps with him and then i think that's
what this is all about it's a weird way
of me saying that i feel like a couple
of these streamer fails we've looked at
are like staged oh no that can't look
real come on yeah the camera can't look
real yeah but you know there is one
streamer that uh you know forgot to turn
off the camera
yeah
yeah do you know have you seen that one
well i know of one i dare not say the
name no he doesn't deserve attention
he's a piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah snoop
dogg rage quitted madden after he lied
however he forgot to turn off the
livestream which went on for eight hours
of nothingness
damn seeing snoop mad that's like
that feels forbidden
i mean how does nobody tell him that
it's owned for eight hours does he have
like
people
bro snoop is always high and happy and
sh why is he mad i cannot this is goals
against everything
come on
this is not the snoop that i thought i
knew no and why is this entire room
painted green if you're gonna put stuff
on the wall anyway what's the point
come on in an attempt no i want to see
the eight hour thing he left them for
eight hours
he probably lives in a freaking huge
mansion and never came back
he comes back
no one told him
snoop dogg realized he's still streaming
after eight hours it's like oh boy let's
go back streaming
no one told them
am i still streaming
oh no snoop has no friends oh no
i'm still streaming off at least youtube
has the button where even though you
click streaming it will
oh
you have to click go live which makes so
much sense i don't know why that's not a
default this twitch doesn't have that do
they yeah you just hit the button on
twitch you just you're just live you're
lying it just goes you're alive that
makes no sense right you wanna check the
audio maybe i don't know there he goes
you have live stream payout oh my god
yeah i've done it twice once
i just i thought i turned it off i i got
up and pushed the button and i had to go
help mary with the kids
yeah downstairs like like watching a
movie with with them yeah i started
getting all these messages oh my god can
you left your stream on all right
like it's just like an empty room okay
it's fine
disaster
walk all the time hanging out you know
oh god but that's why when i'm done i
turn the camera off and everything just
in case exactly you got to make sure and
whenever i enter
the office with my wang out
yeah you best be sure i make sure that
the camera is covered up
it's in the bedroom for me so i don't
want to get the wing out and hey you
know make every other youtuber and
streamer feel inferior you're because
yeah i don't want it you don't want to
feel bad that's very respectful of you
yeah yeah i'm just looking out for the
little guys
but dude the the recording when in the
stream button are like right next to
each other on ops and they look
identical so it's not it's very easy to
anyway
don't be mad
this asmr streamer fell over taking
everything on the computer table with
her
yes
uh
she trying to
is she trying to fart on anything what
is she gonna do
[Music]
lovely asmr sound there thanks
i was so immersed into it
i figured it would be like a little
louder
i love i love robbie 7 000 don't fall
she
if only she had listened
god dang it
wait how has she got youtube and twitch
on her chat right now
let's go see the rules oh you're not
allowed to stream on bob
now twitch has a 24
uh
whatever the word is oh let's see it can
only exist in their platform because i
used to stream a book too you know they
told me to stop and tell me they'd have
to take legal action so
love that love that we're gonna take
legal action we're so glad you're part
of the twitch family but we're going to
take have to take their legal action
like yeah well i mean i get more viewers
if i stream on both so i'm going to
stream on both and they're like oh man
you know you're not really supposed to
be doing that and i was like okay
okay
while playing the game this streamer was
attacked while playing a game yeah we
can see that dipsh valerie magpie that
made its way into his house through the
window
he's australian he's australian dude
you know him oh it says owl
get out of here bird leaves sorry
[Laughter]
supposed to be swooping season
swooping season what is that yeah okay
so for magpie if it's like younger and
like what is a magpie round what is it
called magpie
no that i thought that was a crow
no bye-bye what are you calling himself
uh crow's a crow and it's all
black but they look the same
i thought they were like cats like how
some have that pattern but yeah totally
so anyway during nesting season they
call it swooping season they have babies
and if you're walking near a tree where
a magpie has a nest and it's not it
don't like you then it will swoop at
your head oh yeah
in australia you'll be like this kid
right here getting attacked by the
magpie if you go pick up one
oh my god yeah
that's pretty normal it's awesome you
know you gotta watch out for everything
i guess i seagulls for for uk i don't
know i hate them
let me see what she's up to
[Laughter]
she writing pickle rick what was that
the hot tub meta dude the hot tub i
didn't follow that what happened yeah it
was uh
there was some rule about how you
couldn't be in a bathing suit or in like
revealing clothing unless you're like in
or around the pool
they just
started bringing in their hot their
pools and stuff i think that's the
reason they figured out the system the
young thirsty people and just chatting
would see it and be like oh god
and uh twitch changed it to its own hot
tub tab or whatever and yeah
like nobody watches anymore it's gone
why because because it has its own
category yeah because they moved it off
of just chatting to where you couldn't
like just come across and be like ooh
what is that
majority of the people were doing so
people don't actively seek out that kind
of content it's more like a distraction
it's so it's always been such a weird
conversation of like like people like
girls that use their body to get views
or whatever right or guys poor my
opinion
yeah well in my opinion the the guys
version is or like youtube i'll tell you
the youtubers it's like clickbait
thumbnails like it's got the same thing
to me
no it isn't okay you see it and you go
what is that like boobs in the thumbnail
oh okay
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah and so people
go and look and they go oh what is this
but there's always this thing on twitch
for people like oh these girls are
stealing your views
people go in there and they look and
they go ooh
that's a huh hot girl in a hot tub okay
they sit there for a minute yeah and
they go back about their lives and you
know that's what that's what you think
ken that's what normal people do
i don't think that's the case for
everyone to be fair
well what if you just want to go to just
chat it's [ __ ] distracting you see
someone writing a pickle right what the
[ __ ] is this
tommy whatever you know you can click on
it you know
some some people use their their
gorgeous bodies and their pretty faces
and some use their gleaming
personalities you know i don't have a
problem with it i just find it funny
that the fact that it was put in his own
category is what made it died i think
that kind of proves the point that it is
kind of annoying to have them show up
where they don't maybe don't i don't
know anyway thank you mom opens his team
cheats on stream
on stream
i love these
and then his friend goes whoa whoa
and then he gets banned live right here
good streamer do we open up their names
oh wait is alabama or deadline with that
flag back there behind him i don't know
alabama
no one no one's a fan of alabama ow
wrote hi brother
alabama football god let the tide roll
on them nick saban is a close thing of
jesus jesus christ
where did that come from
oh god
you don't know you don't know about that
college football down down south sec
sounds like the best you're totally
right sounds worse than hot tub mad i'm
not going to lie
at least it's not worse than the mangas
my god i'm glad i got that
this man was strolling down the park
when a golf ball came out of nowhere and
cracked his phone screamed i've had some
bad run-ins with geese i don't know if
it's just me
but oh my god whoa
where did it come from
somebody didn't know four damn yeah they
didn't yell for did they dude golf is
dangerous and i know that as someone
that is very dangerous when they play
golf
you're dangerous and you
oh the one of the houses i was looking
at here in australia is like 10 minutes
away from like a with a top of course
nice yeah i wonder i wanted to buy the
house just so i could like go down the
road and get like a topgolf pass and
just go eat wings and drink beer and
shoot golf what's the topic like a
driving range oh yeah look you should
look up top golf it's freaking crazy
it's like this stacked it's like a
buffalo wild wings with golf yeah yeah
driving range yeah though that's the
yeah they bring you food and beers
oh wow
wow
hey check this out
it's like bowling but for golfing that's
great yeah that's exactly what it is
nice i've done that yeah i've done that
and somewhere it's fun i'm terrible at
golf too
my graduation gift whenever i graduate
high school was a
bag of big bertha golf clubs ooh big
bertha hell yeah i mean why is golf such
an old man sport
well because
it's all about your form right you don't
have to hit that hard no i think it's
getting out of the house for four hours
is that what it is i think that's
literally it
people don't care what they're doing
they just want to have an excuse can't
help but express his appreciation of a
really nice
garden not kid friendly
like making millions of dollars and i
literally show a thigh and i'm
classified as satan so like
[Applause]
yeah just
just the thigh
you're [ __ ] kidding me dude have i
told you about the cleaning videos oh
yes you did that was bizarre
told you about the youtube cleaning
videos yeah same thing same thing we're
going to clean up my room and here's my
butt bruh be naked i don't care but it's
like don't pretend i'm just showing that
bit of a tiny square inch of my thigh
like they pretend that it's not
like bright
the coyote videos where they always
crack a girl's back and she's wearing
like yoga pants their booty jiggles all
over the place same thing don't pretend
that's people aren't there to watch
they're there to watch that booty jiggle
how do you know about this videos can
huh
got to see that again
but bro come on
bruh come on i can't blame him for
trying that
we're already doing that right she's
like dude i mean yo we
we together but we ate that together you
know yeah
you see me smooching you
look he's got his arm around here
she's like no no no no no no hello
did i send any signal no i did not
i was just getting comfortable you know
how dare you yeah i sit there with
everyone my stepdad my
[Laughter]
he tries to kiss me too and i give him
the same treatment
some good crunch yeah it's pretty cringy
love a good live stream fan god i guess
i got one live stream fail now
yeah check out more of my streams guys
if you want to hear me yell at my fans
you don't ask like the same question for
like the 50th time on the day i'm just
like
god my favorite
is that you know when people say trying
to give you directions but they don't
understand that there's a delay in the
in it and there's some context needed if
you say go left i don't know what the
[ __ ] that means okay let's go left go
left
i always get really sarcastic about it
too i'm like oh left and i was like turn
my guy to the left and like look at the
wall oh perfect that's exactly what i
needed to hear
why did you move to australia yeah well
i moved here because my family and my
mary's from australia and she wanted to
be back there for me blah blah blah blah
yeah and then why did you move
so so why'd you move to australia and
i'm just like
oh man
my my favorite is when someone asks a
question that you don't find interesting
enough to warrant a response
they keep asking
i'm like bro if i don't answer take a
haint
jesus christ
another one is like where everyone
assumes like you're best friends with
other youtubers why don't you play with
this person why don't you when are you
going to make a video
like we're like work friends okay like i
don't even talk to them
don't break the illusion come on
what do you mean the illusion that most
youtubers
don't
do even talk to each other unless
they're making a video together yeah i
don't know man anyway
thanks for watching this video can check
out ken and ken
yes why do you move to australia
[Music]
i have new merch represent.com super
happy about this so i think you guys
will like it check it out